In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinek Sadion for August 2 on which we commemorate the translation
of the relics of the Holy Protomarter and Archdeacon Stephen.
On the second of the month, we celebrate the translation of the relics of the Holy Protomarter
and Archdeacon Stephen.
After St. Stephen was stoned by the Jews, Gamelial, St. Paul's teacher in the law, who, convinced
by the Lord's miracles, had been baptized by the apostles, encouraged other Christians
to accompany him and bury the first martyr that had been abandoned on the roadside at
Caffar Gamala, a property of his, about 20 miles from the Holy City.
Once the forty-day morning was passed, Nicodemus, the disciple who went to Jesus by night,
and who had barely escaped the persecution that was unleashed in Jerusalem, arrived in Gamelial's
village, the teacher being his uncle, and asked him for shelter.
He died of his wounds some days later, and was buried beside St. Stephen.
Gamelial and his twenty-year-old son, Habib, who had also been baptized by the apostles, very
soon joined him in death.
A good many years later, when these graves had been forgotten, Lucian, a devout and venerable
priest in the village of Caffar Gamala, saw St. Stephen appear to him three times.
The saint was clad in a linen deacon's sticadion, and he was wearing golden sandals and carrying
a golden staff in his hand.
He smote Lucian lightly with this, calling him by name.
He ordered him to tell John Bishop of Jerusalem to find his relics so that God could work
many miracles through them.
Lucian went at once to inform Bishop John, who ordered him to dig at the place indicated
by the saint, where there stood a heap of stones.
That same night St. Stephen appeared to Lucian once again, to reveal to him that the heap
was only a memorial raised at the time of his funeral, and that he must seek the place
of his burial a little further north.
After he had dug with great haste, a stone plaque was discovered, on which were written
in Hebrew script, the names of St. Stephen, Nicodemus, and Habib.
An earthquake was felt at once, and a sweet fragrance spread around the vicinity, accomplishing
seventy-three healings.
An angelic choir could also be heard singing, glory to God in the highest, and on earth peace
good will among men.
Bishop John, who was then presiding at a synod in Liddah, theospolis, went to the place accompanied
by two other bishops to identify the body of the proto-marter, and he translated it to the
Church of Holy Zion in Jerusalem on the 26th of December in the year 415.
Abundant rain then began to fall, putting an end to the drought that had long been afflicting
Palestine.
It is said that, sometime later, the widow of the founder of the Church in which the relics
of St. Stephen had been placed wanted to take her husband's remains to Constantinople.
But because of the similarity between the two coffins, it was the relics of the saint
that were taken.
The whole length of the journey miracles were wrought as it passed, and when the ship docked
at Calcedon, the demons that were hiding in the waves cried out that an unindurable
fire was tormenting them.
When the ship had landed, the coffin was placed on a wagon drawn by mules.
But the beasts stopped suddenly at a place called Constantinus, and one of them spoke with
the human voice, declaring that the saint's body must be left there.
Even harnessing twelve more mules to the cart was found to be useless in moving it.
The precious relics were therefore placed there on the 2nd of August, and a church was built
there in honor of the proto-marter.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.